highway traffic in Bolivia's farming
region of Santa Cruz has come to a
standstill
protesters want the release of Luis
Camacho the governor of Santa Cruz who
was detained last week
Macho's accused of leading the political
unrest in 2019 that laid to the removal
of then-president evil Morales he denies
the accusations
the ongoing protests are threatening the
delivery of grain and food around the
country
a contracted truck and I carry gas from
Bolivia to Brazil but here the situation
is difficult because of the blockade
people are angry because the governor is
in prison and he's right-wing and they
want him freed then we are paying and
suffering for it because we can't move
on
cargo transport is suffering the
consequence of this political situation
we don't support any political party but
cargo transport Bears a brand of these
situations and its cargo transport
sustains the country's trade
protesters face off against police
they're made with tear gas in return
they set up fireworks Rubble lines the
streets the government is calling for
order
Scandal what these mobilizations seek
with the deterioration of calm and
stability with violence confrontation
hate and tension is to preserve the
impunity of those who participated in
what happened in November 2019 in a
handwritten letter Camacho says
president Luis assay would be
responsible if he died from illness or
anything else Bolivia's government says
his health is stable
for now the situation remains tense with
some saying he needs to be brought to
Justice While others are equating his
freedom with their own Andrea van wyk Al
Jazeera